[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN TONG: Hey, everybody.
How is it going?
We're guessing you're about
a good chunk of the way
through I/O. So it's time to
talk about security stuff.
MAX SALTONSTALL: I have a
security question for you.
JEN TONG: Oh, you do?
MAX SALTONSTALL: Can you
type your password please?
JEN TONG: I can.
You should never do this.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Thank you kindly.
JEN TONG: The demo effect,
it is already upon us
before we've even started.
So we're going to be talking
about securing our apps
and user data with Google
Cloud, just like the title says.
And it is I/O. So I get to talk
about my favorite part of I/O,
which is all of the really cool
applications that all of you
are building.
It's my favorite part, just
kind of meandering around
through the crowd and
talking about the challenges
and excitement that
you're all encountering.
Some people are
writing applications
about travel or finance.
Other people are
writing applications
about staying safe on bicycles.
And it's this
variation in software
that makes all of
our apps special.
It's kind of the reason
we write them anyway.
And this means that it
is very difficult for us
to give you an overall
talk about security that
is perfectly fit for
all of your needs.
Because just like your
applications have things
that are special about
them, the security
needs you have are also
going to be often very
specific to the solutions
you're working on
and the technology
used to implement them.
But we need to talk
about something.
So we are going to talk about
security on an application
that we have developed
in hopes that you
can apply some of this
information to the applications
that you work on.
And that application
is Add a Cat to That.
The way this application works
is you take an awesome photo,
like this photo I took in San
Francisco a couple weeks ago.
I think it's pretty nice
already, the Painted Ladies.
It's a neat landmark.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Could
we make it better?
JEN TONG: We might be
able to make it better
because that is the next step.
You take that photo, you
send it up to the cloud,
and in the cloud, we do
sophisticated artificial
intelligence and send that
photo back to you, improved.
Because everyone knows
that the internet
benefits from more cats.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Can
we make it even better?
JEN TONG: Oh, yes,
we can make it
even better because it
does support recursive
submission of the photos.
The photo that comes
out, you can send it back
to add a cat to that,
and add as many cats
as you want by submitting
it over and over again.
And then once it's ready, once
you've reached sufficient cat
load, you can upload it to your
favorite photo sharing site.
And you are good to go
and properly paying homage
to the true nature
of the internet.
So let's take a quick look
at our application in action.
So if we could go to the demo.
Do you want to switch
to the web browser?
MAX SALTONSTALL: Sure.
JEN TONG: Revealing the code.
Oh, here it is.
Here's Add a Cat to That in
our wonderful mobile first
interface.
We're going to submit one of
my favorite pictures of cake,
because food photos are the
other half of the internet.
We'll add a caption
so that everyone knows
what we think of the photo.
And our photo is improved.
Yay.
But this is a
developer conference.
You're not here just
to see our interface.
So let's take a look
at the code and see
how we've implemented this.
Here is the truth about
Add a Cat to That.
We're not doing any
sophisticated machine
learning yet because this is
our MVP, our Minimum Viable
Product, just enough to go out
and try and raise the money.
It's actually a very
short Python program,
about 20 lines of
code, implemented using
a micro framework called Flask.
And all it really does is
the photo gets posted up.
And then we fork
off a sub process
to a common image manipulation
program called ImageMagick,
take the results, and
send it back to our users.
And this is pretty
easy to get together.
Then we had to think
about how we're
going to run the software.
This is a greenfield
application,
like we're starting
from scratch.
So we have the
opportunity to take
advantage of a lot of the new
cool development techniques.
And that's where Docker
came in so that we
can enable fast development
environment creation
and easy deployment
to production.
And we packaged it all up in a
Docker file, which was a snap.
We went to Docker, got
the Hello World tutorial,
and just changed it, so that
the Python 3.7 base image is now
uploading or now combining all
the files for our application
and then running it in
Unicorn of Flask runner.
Cool.
So with that, let's go--
oh, wait, one more thing.
We want to look and see how
we're running it in production.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Yep.
JEN TONG: So we're going to
go on over to the console.
Since we are also using
a Docker container,
not only did we get the benefits
of a really easy development
environment to kick
up, but we also
have a whole bunch of
places that we can almost
click a button and
run it in production.
And at the current stage
of Add a Cat to That,
we are using the beta cloud
run, which we made available
a few weeks back.
And it's a really
great fit for us.
We uploaded the image,
used Cloud Build,
and it was pretty much turnkey,
pointed it at our domain.
And we were ready to start
pitching our application
for the next round of funding.
But this is when the
next question came up,
which, if we can go
back to the slides,
this is when the
question of security
finally started to come on.
We're going around.
We're talking to
potential investors,
and we're getting this
question over and over again.
Everyone wants to know if
our application is secure.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Is it secure?
JEN TONG: That's a
little more complicated.
I guess we'll be getting into
that with most of the session.
Over and over again,
we heard horror stories
of people's previous investments
ending up in the headlines.
But the truth is security is
not really a binary thing.
It's not a yes or no question.
You don't just flip a switch,
and suddenly your application
is secure.
It's much more
complex than that.
A little fuzzy, maybe even
like a kind of a gradient
is another way of
thinking about it.
To work towards a more
secure application,
to move further
along that spectrum,
we need to do some work.
We need to put on
our attacker hat
and do an exercise
called threat modeling.
In threat modeling, what
you do is you take advantage
of the fact that
you are probably
the best person to
attack your software
since you know
everything about it--
or most of the things.
And then you use what you
learned from that process
to make your application safer.
One of the foundations
of this technique
is that a hacker's probably
not just going to randomly hack
at your software.
Well, they might,
but probably not.
They're probably after
something specific.
They probably have
a goal in mind.
This might be your user data.
This might be
financial information
that you have in a database.
Or the truth is the
goal could actually
be outside your organization.
They might be using
you as a stepping stone
to get at something else.
Like, they might want
to take advantage
of an open source library you
maintain that other people use.
But they won't be able to
get straight at that goal.
Because it's
important to you, it's
probably pretty well protected.
So an attacker is going to look
for intermediate resources.
They're going to
investigate your environment
and try and find
different things that they
can take advantage of to pivot
and move around and make it
further into your system.
These intermediate
resources could
be things like servers
running in a cluster,
but they can also be things
like libraries you depend on
or even your
developers themselves.
And as they investigate,
they're also
going to try and learn about
any defensive measures you have
in place, anything from password
policies, to auditing you do,
to firewall rules, and the like.
They're probably going to start
the process of enumerating
all these things
from information
they can publicly find
online, like photos
from your last
company party that
made it up to LinkedIn somehow.
And maybe they'll get a
foothold in at some point.
And they'll spend time very
carefully and gradually
enumerating all those
intermediate resources
and all those defensive
measures you have in place.
Until they find a way to string
them all together to wiggle
around defensive measures
you have in place,
and strike at that goal, and
get access to that information,
or plant that malware, or
whatever they want to do.
And this is called a kill chain.
This part can
happen very quickly.
But what we want to do
is we want to defend
against those threats.
And our first impulse might
be after doing some threat
modeling and figuring out a
kill chain that someone might
be able to do would be to take
one of our defensive measures
and just beef it up--
more firewall rules,
more broken down network,
that kind of stuff.
But that's not always the
best investment of your time.
Going straight to
our pet solutions
is not always the
best thing we can do.
It turns out that often
a better use of your time
is to focus on removing
unnecessary things that
could potentially be
intermediate resources,
and of the ones that
you need to keep,
reducing the attack surface
to make them smaller.
And in addition to
that, rather than have
one strong defensive measure
in place in a certain area,
it's more effective to have
a greater number of easier
to maintain defensive
measures that overlap,
so that if one fails, another
one might get triggered.
And this technique is
called defense in depth.
So that if one thing
fails for whatever reason,
you have another backup
behind it to help protect you.
And this is the philosophy that
we believe in very strongly
at Google.
So we all have multiple
different things
we want to protect.
Today we're going to be talking
about a few different things
that you can do to establish
that defense in depth.
We're going be talking about
secure supply chain, which
is about making sure you don't
deploy bad code that someone
else wrote, or deploy
dependencies that
might have problems that
we already know about.
We're going to talk about
automatic vulnerability
scanning, so that we can
find that low hanging fruit,
those silly mistakes we
make that we kick ourselves
when we find, before someone
else finds them for us.
And we're going to talk about
the nut behind the wheel,
another potential weakness,
making sure that phishing
does not cause us a problem.
Because phishing is something
that we often joke about
and we tease people.
But it's a surprisingly
effective technique
in offensive security,
despite the fact
that we were all immune
to phishing, obviously.
Surprisingly not.
So first, let's dig into
one of those deeper.
Let's talk about
secure supply chain
in the context of
Add a Cat to That.
So Add a Cat to That is
a very short program.
Like you saw, it has a
dozen lines of code that's
kind of the core functionality.
But believe it or not, it
has hundreds of dependencies.
And one of the
things that made it
so easy to write
Add a Cat to That
is we all kind of stand on
the shoulders of giants.
We get to include a lot
of other people's work
to get started very quickly
and make very rapid progress
as developers.
But some of those things we
depend on might be neglected,
or someone else might
have made a mistake.
So that's a really
large surface for things
to potentially go wrong.
And we don't want to be sad.
And in fact, we can
kind of get an idea
of how big this risk is.
In 2018, there were over 16,000
published vulnerabilities
called CVEs in
vulnerability databases.
And that's way too many
to keep track of manually.
So if we tried to
subscribe to newsletters
and then kind of investigate
Add a Cat to That
each time to see
if we're impacted,
we're never going to
be able to keep up.
But we're software
developers, and when
we encounter a
problem like that,
we solve it with software.
And fortunately, we are using
Google Container Registry
to store our container
images before we push them
to production in cloud run.
And I'd like to show
you a feature of that
that can help us keep
our supply chain secure.
So with that, let's
go back to the demo.
So here is the Container
Registry, where all of the Add
a Cat to That images
are published.
And if we go over to the
Settings pane of Container
Registry, we will
see a feature that
is normally off by default.
It is a beta feature,
but it is awesome.
It is worth checking,
even if you're
a little bit beta skittish.
We've already enabled
it ahead of time.
It's called
Vulnerability Scanning.
And now if we go back
to our list of images
and go into our web
application image,
you will see a new column
has appeared on the far side.
And if we click
into that, we will
see that our image, which will
only have a few dependencies,
or so we thought, and a
dozen lines of actual code,
has over 600 vulnerabilities
and only 38 fixes.
That's like 6% or 7%
that even can be fixed.
So it's at this point that a lot
of people might start to panic.
But don't panic.
It's OK.
It's better that we know
about these early on, right?
MAX SALTONSTALL:
How are we going
to solve 600 vulnerabilities?
JEN TONG: Well, first, let's
investigate if any of them
are actually relevant to us
because these vulnerabilities
are related to the
dependencies we use,
but they might not
actually impact
the way we use our application.
So let's click in on one
of the ImageMagick wands
because that's one
of the things we use.
And here, you'll find details
on exactly what it is.
Like, this one is an
initialized variable
leading to memory corruption.
So if we wanted to, we could
dig through the potential use
cases.
We could do a threat modeling.
We could look through
all the use cases
that Add a Cat to
That does and see
if this is even relevant to us.
And even if there's not a fix
we might be able to set up,
we might be able to
do defense in depth,
instead of a secondary
measure that protects us
from this particular issue,
although this one looks
kind of bad.
So let's see if we can come
up with a different way
to mitigate this issue.
So for that, let's look
at an experiment round.
So if we go back to the code,
we did an experiment-- well,
first of all, when
we looked at all
of our potential
vulnerabilities,
we noticed that a
whole bunch of them
are related to ImageMagick.
ImageMagick is wonderful.
It is super fast, but it
is also very complicated
and has a lot of
vulnerabilities that get
discovered in it as a result.
So we discover that
there is a pure Python
implementation we
can do to implement
the exact same functionality.
It's a Python library
called Pillow.
And with just a few
lines of code change,
we were able to re-implement
Add a Cat to That
and remove the forked
ImageMagick process from it,
which is a huge win.
Another thing we
did was we tweaked
our Docker file a little bit.
As much as the Hello
World Python 3.7
image got us started
fast, it turns out
it had a whole
bunch of stuff in it
that we didn't need at all,
which were well represented
in that vulnerability list.
So we went and grabbed a
slimmed down base image.
And there's a lot
of these available.
We chose Alpine
Linux for this one.
And we added a little
more work here.
We had to explicitly install
all of our real dependencies.
But other than that, the Docker
file's pretty much the same.
But with that one
little change, boop,
we shot it back up
to Container Registry
and stuck it in
the experimental.
And you will notice that if we
go over to the Vulnerabilities
tab-- oh, you can
see right it there,
too-- it shows up in the
interface a few places.
Surprisingly, I thought
there would still
be some vulnerabilities, but
it got it all the way back down
to zero with just a
tiny little change.
And the truth is that this
change did have a cost.
It is slower, and it
uses more memory now.
But that is the decision
that we have to make.
We have to decide if the
performance overhead is
worth it to this, or if we
want to put in other maybe
more complicated or time--
more difficult interventions
in place to prevent it.
In this case, at least for
us, we're at the MVP stage.
We just want to
show some cool demos
and not get pwned
in the process.
This is a great solution for us.
So with that, I guess
we're probably ready to go.
MAX SALTONSTALL: I
think we're done.
Yeah?
JEN TONG: Well, I don't know.
Why don't you tell
us a little bit more?
MAX SALTONSTALL: Let's
go back to the slides.
So I think everything's
secure now, right?
Because we fixed all
of the dependency
chain, and we just eliminated
600 vulnerabilities
in a matter of minutes by
making those two changes.
JEN TONG: And we review
all our code every night.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Especially
2:00 in the morning.
JEN TONG: Usually at 2:00
to 3:00 in the morning.
MAX SALTONSTALL: The
night before the demo.
JEN TONG: Yeah, after.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So maybe
we've made some mistakes.
Maybe you all have
made some mistakes,
and your code is
not 100% perfect.
Because we all
introduce some bugs.
Well, I also want to tell
you about a tool that
can help you there.
So Google's web security scanner
will do automated testing
of your deployed code
to find those bugs
that you've introduced
vulnerabilities
unintentionally.
And rather than tell
you all about it.
Let's just show you.
Let's switch to the laptop.
JEN TONG: Sure.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So
we're going to bring up
Cloud Security Scanner
once we switch to our demo.
And what you can see here
is the simple web UI in GCP.
Let's make a new scan just
to walk through the steps.
It's very, very fast.
So as we make a new
scan, we're going
to point this at a
staging URL for our app
because this is actually going
to be fuzz testing our web app.
And you don't want to point that
at your production instance.
But you're going
to be interesting
a whole lot of
wacky data, and it
might corrupt your application.
So point it at something
in staging your dev.
We've put in the Kubernetes
pod address there.
The rest of these things
you can leave as default.
I would head down and
make this run daily,
so it can automatically
update you
when any new issues are
found because of a new push.
So we're going to say this is
going to take about 15 minutes
or so to actually get going,
so let me show you one cat
scan that we made earlier,
just so you can see what
some of that output looks like.
Now our code's
totally safe, right?
Right?
JEN TONG: There's some
issues, it looks like.
Scanner found stuff.
MAX SALTONSTALL: All right.
Let's see what the cross-site
scripting issues are.
JEN TONG: OK,
those can be scary.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Yeah, so
the web security scanner
starts crawling around
all the URLs it can find
and starts looking for
these known vulnerabilities.
In this case, it found a
cross-site scripting bug
in our admin login page.
And what it's
giving us right here
is the exact way to
replicate that bug,
so that we can troubleshoot
and then fix it.
So we're going to make--
JEN TONG: Sure.
Let's take a look at
the test data it gave us
so we can reproduce it.
I'm going to drop
that into a new file.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So we're going
to show you this bug live,
and then we're going
to fix it right now, so
that we can knock yet
another vulnerability off
of Add a Cat to That.
Because we don't want
our cats to be insecure.
So taking that HTML from
Web Security Scanner,
we can see here that
doesn't look right.
JEN TONG: No, it should
say the email address
of the person who tried to
log in, not some weird stuff.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Yeah,
that's pretty weird.
Let's go to the login page HTML
and see if we can fix this.
JEN TONG: OK, it's right here.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
So this login page,
which is called out by
Web Security Scanner,
this is where that
HTML came from.
And yeah, I remember
now what happened.
Back when we were writing
this the first time,
we assumed anything
submitted to this form
was going to be totally
safe because it was going
to be just coming from inside.
JEN TONG: Right,
because we wanted people
to have email addresses
with pictures.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Yeah, now that
we're getting ready to launch,
maybe we should reconsider that.
JEN TONG: That's an easy fix.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Let's take that out.
JEN TONG: Remove that.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
All right, now we're
allowing the cross-site
scripting prevention
that we had actually
disabled before.
I'm sorry for the
double negative.
So we push that fixed build
to production right now.
And the coolest part about
this whole process and the tool
is that the Web Security
Scanner doesn't cost you
anything to use.
This is free.
It's very easy.
It's not perfect.
Neither is your
code, but it's going
to catch a lot of those
common, easy to prevent errors.
It's not going to protect you
from a sophisticated attack
or a new clever zero-day.
But it will help you with
things that may have slipped
past your code review process.
Very low friction, and
it's fire and forget.
Once you set up that daily
scan, it's going to keep going.
All right.
Let's go back to the slides.
So we have secured
our dependency chain
by fixing some of
those library issues.
We've made sure
our code is secure.
Now we're safe, right?
There's no possible
way someone could
compromise Add a Cat to That.
Well, what if somebody
manages to get
into my account or Jen's account
with a good phishing attack?
All of those previous
protections are useless.
So I want to talk
about the people
and how you can
secure the people
with better authentication.
A typical login flow
looks something like this.
You present your login and
password to the server.
And then you're in.
Oh no.
Somebody was actually giving
you a very clever phishing page.
You've given them
your credentials.
And now they're logging
in and doing anything
that you could have done.
They can modify
your source code.
They could add some malware.
They could sign a malicious
binary with your keys.
This is terrible.
There's a lot of bad things,
but you think, I'm good.
I have this one time password
that my phone gives me.
JEN TONG: It doesn't
always work, though.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Aw, man.
So the phisher can just take
that one time password, too.
And now they're
passing it forward,
and they're logging in as
you just as successfully.
This doesn't actually
prevent phishing.
So I want to tell you
about a better way.
These security keys,
which you can either
get as USB key or Bluetooth,
and now you can actually
use your Android phone,
thanks to announcement
a few weeks ago from Google.
These will do a much
stronger second factor
to make your login secure.
So I want to replay
that previous scenario
in a way that's going to
stop phishing in its tracks.
Instead of being complete,
after you give login
name and password, the server
replies with a challenge.
It knows that you registered a
security key onto your account
already.
And it has the public encryption
key for that security key.
So you get that challenge
back, and your security key,
when you tap it, is actually
verifying the domain
that it's talking to.
That means a phishing
domain, even a very cleverly
disguised one with a URL that
looks almost exactly the same,
except for that weird
ASCII character that it's
using that's not really
an O, but looks like an O,
won't work.
The key won't sign
that challenge
and return if the domain isn't
exactly what it was set up
with.
The domain checks out.
Your security key signs
it, returns a challenge.
Now the server can
validate that you
used a key that it
expected that you already
registered in the past.
So it knows that you not
only possess your password,
but you also possess that key,
something you know something
you have.
Now you've authenticated
in a way that's extremely
resistant to phishing.
We've been using
this a lot at Google,
and it's really effective.
Let's switch to the demo.
I'm going to show
you how it works.
So Jen, why don't you log in?
Here's your account,
put in the password.
And now it's going to
ask for one more step--
security key.
Plug that in, give it a tap.
All right, we are in.
Now, Jen's a super
admin on this domain.
We definitely want to
protect those accounts.
It's really, really important.
So I would recommend that you
use security keys for everyone.
It's not practical
in all circumstances.
So let's say you want
to set it up just
for your engineering team.
Let's go into the security
settings in our Google Admin,
and we're going to go
look at our basic settings
and get into the advanced
2-factor 2-step security
settings.
From here, we can choose
what kind of enforcement.
Let's turn on 2-factor
for end of May.
But actually, we also
want to make sure
that we're doing this for
people where it really matters.
So we can set it up just
for the engineering group.
JEN TONG: Right, we can
probably get them keys in time.
MAX SALTONSTALL: The whole
two-person engineering team.
JEN TONG: Exactly.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Perfect.
So we can select the
engineering team right here.
And now we can say turn on
enforcement for the end of May.
And you can decide what kinds
of 2-step authentication
you're going to allow.
I think we only
want security keys
because as we just
learned, an OTP is just
as phishable as a password.
As soon as we save
this, we're set.
It's as easy as that.
All right.
Let's go back to the slides.
So we've had you here
for a little while.
We've been working on
an Add a Cat to That.
What do you think?
Have we made it more secure?
Yeah?
Are we done?
No?
Well, let's review
what we have done.
We've secured our supply chain
with Google Container Registry
and scanned to find
some dependencies
that we needed to remove.
We have looked at our
own code in our web app
to find some cross-site
scripting vulnerabilities
that we could also fix.
And we've added
stronger authentication
for our engineering
team, so it's
much harder for
someone malicious
to take over one
of our accounts.
But you're not all
making Add a Cat to That.
At least, I hope not
because if you are,
I have a lawyer who
needs to talk to you.
Your software is
different than ours.
And that means the
threats you face
are going to be different
than what we're looking at.
And what's important
to you might not
be as important to us.
You need to have your
own security strategy.
So this is the
beginning, and I hope
that you'll explore some
of the security features
in Google Cloud or the other
platforms that you're using.
And I hope that you'll do
a little bit of exploration
of the documentation.
I also want you to do
some threat modeling.
Put on that attacker
hat, figure out
what someone who knows a
lot about your application
could do, if they were
feeling especially nasty.
This is the start
of your journey,
but it's just the beginning.
Thank you very much
for joining us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]